[rock music]
- ♪ SAVING EARTH FROM SPACE
♪ POWER FALCONS!
- [roars]
[falcon screech]
[growls]
- YELLOW FALCON,
WHAT DO YOUR SENSES TELL YA?
- DESTRUCTO IS
A KILLING MACHINE.
- [growls]
- HIS ARMOR IS IMPERVIOUS
TO OUR BLASTERS.
YOU GOT ANY IDEAS,
RED FALCON?
- SURE DO, YELLOW FALCON.
BLUE FALCON, YOU REMEMBER
OUR BATTLE AT DANGO BLUFF?
I'LL TAKE THE LEGS,
YOU TAKE THE BLASTERS.
- IT WAS BEAVER CREEK,
AND I TOOK THE LEGS.
MAKE SURE YOU SHORE UP
THAT FLANK, BLACK FALCON.
- UM, ARE YOU TALKING TO ME?
BECAUSE I'M
THE GREEN FALCON.
- NO TIME FOR THAT,
BLACK FALCON.
PURPLE FALCON,
ARM MISSILES!
- ROGER THAT.
ARMING MISSILES NOW.
[machinery whirring]
- UH--
- BATTLE FORMATIONS.
WE'RE GOING IN.
- HEY.
- ROGER THAT.
- HOLD UP.
- COPY THAT.
- ROGER.
- MY FALCON IS GREEN.
- HEY, HEY, HEY.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT
OUR FALCON COLORS WHEN WE GET
BACK TO BASE, BLACK FALCON.
RIGHT NOW,
WE GOT A MISSION TO DO.
FALL INTO FALCON FORMATION.
[screaming, explosion]
- WELL, NOW, HERE'S THE ISSUE
IS THAT, YOU'RE GONNA
GIVE ME AN ORDER, I'M NOT GONNA
KNOW YOU'RE TALKING TO ME.
'CAUSE...I'M NOT
IN A BLACK FALCON.
- COME ON, CHILL IT OUT,
BLACK FALCON.
- YEAH, BLACK FALCON,
RELAX.
- FIRST OF ALL,
I DON'T LIKE THE WAY
YOU GUYS ARE SAYING "BLACK."
SECOND OF ALL,
THERE IS NO BLACK FALCON!
I'M GREEN FALCON!
- BLACK FALCON, HOMIE,
NO ONE'S TRYING TO GET UP
IN YOUR GRILL HERE.
- UH-UH, UH-UH, UH-UH.
DON'T TALK TO ME LIKE THAT.
NO, DON'T SAY "GRILL"
LIKE THAT.
I'M THE GREEN FALCON,
AND I--
- OH, STOP BEING
SO BLACK FALCON ABOUT IT.
- WHAT THE [bleep]
DO YOU MEAN BY THAT?
- BLACK FALCON, BROTHER,
I UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU'RE GOING THROUGH.
- DO YOU?
NO, I DON'T THINK YOU DO.
HOW WOULD YOU FEEL IF
I CALLED YOU RED FALCON, HUH?
- WHOA!
- AND PURPLE FALCON,
HOW WOULD YOU FEEL IF I CALLED
YOU YELLOW FALCON, HUH?
- THAT'S RACIST.
- THAT WAS RACIST.
- YEAH, THAT'S RACIST.
- OOH, THAT IS RACIST.
- THAT'S RACIST?
OH, SEE, OKAY, NOPE, FORGET IT.
BLACK FALCON OUT--
GREEN FALCON!
[whoosh]
GREEN FALCON! DAMN IT!
- HEY! WHY'D THAT GREEN FALCON
FALL OUT OF FALCON FORMATION?
BLACK FALCON,
GET ON THAT AND REPORT BACK.
BLACK FALCON?
BLACK FALCON, COME IN.
[rock music]
- ♪ SAVING EARTH FROM SPACE
♪ POWER FALCONS!